I can't believe it's his 13th season
13th training camp heading into the
National Football League he is Greg
Olson the Carolina Panthers how are you
Greg
doing great man how's it going I'm doing
great I mean walk me through is this
like because you got kids is this do you
have like a checklist like a
back-to-school checklist you need this
you need that before you head off I mean
what's this week like for you oh man
this week is you cram everything that
you've been putting off all summer
personally into two days to make sure
you check all those boxes before you
leave you make sure all's right with the
Y's you make sure all the right with you
did you make sure they all love you
you're not going to see you for three
weeks
make sure there's no there's no loose
ends at home that you didn't that you
ignored for the last couple months you
want to make sure you leaving home on
the right foot okay so the honey-do list
I mean can you can you walk me like
what's the biggest item that you
definitely needed to lock up on that
front
my list is long rich I got I got I am
fortunate that I have a wife who takes
care of mostly everything at home but my
biggest thing really is in all
seriousness just enjoy the last couple
days with the kids enjoy you know
something as simple as having dinner and
then going out in the backyard and
making s'mores because in the next three
weeks we're not gonna be able to do it
and after dinner if they want to go for
ice cream go right just just those last
couple things that all offseason maybe
you take for granted because you could
always do it tomorrow we can do it
tomorrow the next day because you have
pretty much a lot of free time well
those those nights are now at a premium
so it's a the hardest part is as I've
gotten older and the kids have gotten
older is just leaving them you know for
such a long stretch of time outside of a
few training camp visits and whatnot but
uh it's it's all part of the deal we've
had a great offseason together and
gotten to do a lot of stuff and now it's
time to get back to work now it's time
to get back to work you're heading to
South Carolina or Spartans burg
Spartanburg pardon me Wofford College
where things go down and you are gonna
be there in a couple days to get it all
started how are you feeling Greg let's
start with that I feel great
you know I've had a reason I was a
couple minutes getting in we just got
off the field doing a little workout
over at the stadium we I feel great I've
had a great offseason I haven't been
limited you know for months now was able
to go through the whole offseason
programs and OTAs and training camp you
know I feel great
you know I feel as good as I have it's
just a matter of the last couple years I
just been a little snick snake bit by
this foot and you know hopefully that's
behind me I haven't had any knock on
wood haven't had any really you know
setbacks or anything holding me back so
hopefully it lacks a little bit better
this time the surgery we did after the
second break was a little bit more
significance we're hoping it provides a
little more you know stability and kind
of put that thing to rest for the first
time and Don feels like forever but in
two years now so why do you keep doing
it Greg I mean you you you have a
broadcasting career teed up if you want
it I don't know if let's let me let me
start with this then have you gotten
knocks on the door to say just quit and
we'll put you in a booth have you gotten
those calls from people in my industry
we have last offseason we had some
significant talks this year we probably
had the most significant talks with a
few different networks about a few
different types of jobs whether it be
broadcast stuff studio stuff calling
games or whatnot and a lot of them were
really intriguing you know I enjoy it
but fortunately do a lot of different a
lot of different sorts of stuff whether
it's calling games are doing the combine
or you know doing studio stuff before
the Super Bowl and I've really enjoyed
it but you know when it came down to it
you know it was just really hard for me
to walk away considering how the last
two years went you know to have if that
was my way I had to go out and the team
was pushing me out the door and that was
really the end of the run for me and I
just couldn't do it anymore than fine
but I just feel like I had I had
something less than I needed to go out
and finish on my terms
finish my last season potentially or one
of my last season's potentially on a
better note playing the game that I had
been accustomed to playing at a high
level for 10 plus years prior to being
hurt the last two so I just knew I would
look back and regret walking away on
such a sour note and you know we'll see
we'll see what happens once I'm done and
see what opportunities are out there
what do you love about Greg what do you
love about those that's football aspect
over there about playing yeah what do
you I mean that keep that keeps the fire
burning here I mean the part that I
still really enjoy that a lot of the
other guys I think when you hear about
older guy
start their careers start coming to an
end and they can't play at such a high
level anymore it's typically more
because they're just not willing to do
the offseason stuffs anymore and I get
it
the offseasons get long getting up in
February and March and training in the
morning on your own is hard going
through OTAs you have a hundred other
things you got family you got kids you
got other things you want to get into
it's not easy but I still really enjoy
that part I still enjoy running around
with the younger guys I still enjoyed
you know challenging myself and whether
it's in the weight room or on the field
being disciplined with my offseason
programs being disciplined with my
training finding new ways to you know
what new ways can I incorporate training
into my program to have more longevity
more durability and just continuing to
seek out people who know that world I
just really enjoy that challenge I think
everyone approaches the actual season
the same way I think everybody enjoys
the games I think that part's easy it's
what can you do between February and
July August and training camp to get
yourself ready to have success and when
that part of it is over for me and I
don't want to get up any more and do
that then then I know it'll be time for
me to be done Greg Olson Panthers tight
end right here on the Rich Eisen show
you know the owner nothing series that's
on Amazon that came out from your team
last year that's out right now for a lot
of people to see cam one of the guys has
been surprising you know to see him
mixed up obviously they had a good one
of the some great one great scene was
him and Luke Kuechly going back and
forth with your former teammate Josh
Norman I mean seeing cam right in the
mix with all the guys again has been
surprising to some I'm wondering what
you could tell me on that front why why
you think maybe some people be surprised
by that Greg I haven't seen the show yet
you know I've seen little clips and
stuff and read what people have talked
about and whatnot but you know he that's
the way it's been since he's been here I
know I don't know what the I mean I
guess I do kind of know what the
national kind of thought of him is and
the perspective of the outside is of him
but um you know inside the building
since he's gotten here has really didn't
no different than what you just said
he's been one of the guys he's he's a
fun guy to have a
good energy he's got good positive
impact on the guys around there who
brings a lot of energy to practice the
meetings he's got a he's got a funny
side that brings a lot of humor when
when things get tight and he it he's
been now for you know eight years you
know just like everybody else you know
one of the guys in the middle of the
jokes in the middle of the fun he takes
his own he gives a little of his own so
I'm glad that they were able to kind of
capture some of those moments and kind
of share that with people who don't get
to see him as much as we do on a daily
basis around here for sure well in terms
of being locked in on what I guess the
job is which quarterbacks certainly of
his stature and certainly of his ability
and success would show one thing that
left out at me that clearly he's
focusing on something other than just
pop culture's somebody had to explain to
him and others what Hamilton was and
that got picked up you were the guy who
is explaining what Hamilton musical is
about and who's in it Greg what gives
there I loved it I went so Hamilton when
it first came out I did too a couple
years ago and it was just um it was what
everyone you know it's one of those few
times in life where people hide
something up and you're like Aaron I got
to go see it and most of the time you
walk out and you're like okay it was
good maybe not as much as the height but
like you walk out and you were like wow
that was just incredibly different
unique and something that you're just
not accustomed to seeing so I don't know
how it came up it came up we were
sitting on the bench I saw the clip
online and the guys weren't really sure
it was and as you can see from the
conversation it was really me trying to
explain Hamilton as a hip-hop musical
Broadway play to a bunch of guys who
didn't really understand the whole it's
a very interesting conversation I don't
know how much they care but once they
gave me the opening I was going to be
sure that by the end of that
conversation they were at least gonna go
home and Google Amal tensing and get an
idea of what it was all about I guess if
Hamilton doesn't show up on the game
film they you know and it doesn't matter
is that what you tell I know I asked
Mike did you guys are on your phone 12
hours a day not one of you
social media came across Hamilton it was
like the most talked about pop culture
event going on for like six months a
couple years ago like you guys don't
know what that musical is and lin-manuel
more ants like you don't and you never
saw that right you're like no I was like
you guys got to get off video games and
start getting out a little bit you know
and it's interesting too I know you're
again your teammates with Cam and you've
known him for a long time you're the
same height as him if if he asked you to
get up out of your seat for the
transatlantic flight that's coming up
for the Panthers London game that I'll
be calling surely would you would you
get would you give him your seat yeah I
mean in the 1500 bucks I guess he needs
to up that that that seat change fee to
get understand supply and demand that
that price if you're gonna pay a guy
that short notice you're gonna have to
come out of your pocket a little more
than that yeah I thought so too I mean
he gave it a whirl though didn't work
I'll give him credit he gave it a shot
you can't hurt you can't you can't hate
the hustle he gave it his best shot yeah
I mean you've got a London game coming
up it's on the NFL Network too Greg
that's coming it well I'm looking
forward one of the things that I've
always looked forward to in my whole
career I've never played an
international game obviously the London
or the Mexico one and I'm finally the
year I was supposed to play with you
might last year in Chicago they were on
they were scheduled to play and then
obviously I got traded to Carolina so I
never I never got to go so I had a wait
nine years from when I was supposed to
play my first one too now finally get a
chance to play overseas I've never been
to Europe in general let alone played a
game there so I'm uh I'm looking forward
to that a lot do you never have sets
loaded in the continent of Europe
negative I have not set foot on like the
other half of the globe I haven't been
met
I haven't been to Europe hadn't been
Asia Africa I've been to like Mexico
I've been to like all the normal
American guys been there like the
Caribbean I've been to Caribbean you
know Mexico I have been to Hawaii and
that's pretty much pretty much it you're
gonna be playing
in tottenham hotspur stadium new the Oh
new White Hart Lane it's gonna be great
against the the pant the Panthers versus
the Bucks two and I'll tell you what man
I mean I'm looking forward to that game
again that's on on NFL Network week six
right there in the middle of October
this division Greg it just seems to be
now with Aryans at the head coach a spot
in Tampa that seems to be a perfect
marriage for Jameis Winston right now
and then you're a near two with the nor
of offense there and we all know when
cam was healthy last year what that
looked like
we know that the Saints and the sent
minds of many Saints fans should have
been in the Superbowl and the Atlanta
Falcons appear to be absolutely loaded i
I don't know how the heck this division
gets sorted out Greg I wonder what your
thoughts are on this yeah in the last
couple years the the reality has been I
mean you'd be hard-pressed to find a
better division you know and you know
either conference as good as as the
south you know the NFC South and you
know it all starts with quarterbacks and
if you look around the league you know
to have the four quarterback so we have
in our league I mean even though the
best way to sum it up is last year the
worst team in our division you know the
last couple years the Bucs have had the
number one offense in the league so I
mean you go you're you're talking about
going to play what's supposed to be the
easiest of your six division games and
you're still getting ready to play a
team that's going to put up 30 points 25
30 points and 400 yards of offense a
game I mean that's supposed to be your
easy game you know so anytime you play
against high-caliber quarterbacks you
know we got three number one overall
pick quarterbacks and in our division
and then the fourth one is Drew Brees so
it's it's it's a tough six games that
you know you're starting with each year
and you know now as each team has gotten
younger and better on defense
to go with their you know quarterback
play and their high-powered offense and
their ability to throw the ball and the
guys on the outside that they have at
receiver it's it's a really difficult
division to come out of but at the same
time I think it's you know it prepares
us and we've competed you know right
there with everybody over the last
couple years you know obviously the last
season to haven't been as great for us
as they were the previous when we want
it three times in a row there for a
while but um
it's the division is as good as any I
think like you said we know Aryans but
from his time when we competed at a high
level in the NFC against the Cardinals
you know when you're in the NFC
Championship with Aryans and that run
they had for a couple years so he'll get
them back rolling again and to go along
with what they're doing in Atlanta and
New Orleans so we got our work cut out
for us that's we know six games a year
are going to be are gonna be tough and
then you'd see who you're out you know
who your division AFC divisional you
know group is and what your NFC you know
cross group is it's a tough schedule
when you start with tips like that
absolutely and last one for you Greg I'm
gonna give you a question if you were
part of the paparazzi you're an analyst
this is exactly the one that they would
ask you and they being the sports media
and I guess I'm part of that so I'm
gonna give it to you right here just
gonna if you don't mind throw it right
at you this is not this is not Greg
Olson the football player although
drawing on on the position that you play
and the concept of still wanting to play
in the NFL do you think Gronk plays in
the NFL this fall for the New England
Patriots Greg Olson if I was betting I
would bet yes I don't think it I I think
it's close to maybe 6040 5050 I don't
think it's like a no-brainer I just
think he's buying a little time I think
if you look at his offseason in the last
couple years there's been I want you
know I want a new contract we amended
the contract we've kind of done all
those things you never really got what
he wanted I think this might be a way of
saying hey let me save myself through
camp
let me save myself to the beginning of
the season the beginning of the season
never matters to the Patriots anyway
every September everyone thinks they're
dead I don't think those games really
matter that much around there when
things are getting starts getting
serious in November I think if they find
themselves in a run and he's available I
think there's a realistic shot that they
bring him out and say hey come play 25
snaps for us play in the red zone play
on third down give a little extra juice
to the offense and help us make the
late-season run that were accustomed to
kind of urine and you're out to put us
put ourselves in you know one of the top
couple spots in the AFC I I don't think
that's an unrealistic
kind of bath sir certainly if tea b12 is
the one to love in the call right Greg I
mean how significant in that big yeah
Tom Brady calls you in end of October
November says hey grant were we're
sitting here halfway through the year
five and three six and two we're right
in the mix of this thing you know come
put us over the hump the last eight
games and let's get it you know make
another run III I'll say I'd be
surprised if it didn't happen you'd have
to show me he's retired for a full 16
games before I really buy it Greg you're
the man always appreciated that's as
well and by the way that was great
before I let you go real quick you you
shot some a video of somebody proposing
this offseason why did that most random
thing can you walk me through that real
quick before I let you go here that
happened I was down and I was down in
Nashville speaking at this health care
you know conference or whatever and I
got back to my hotel room that night
after the event and dinner and we're
walking and me and my buddy and we're
walking down the lobby of the big opera
big Opryland or whenever called down in
Nashville like a huge huge hotel
and we're walking across like this sky
bridge which is kind of like the lobby
and this guy and a girl are holding
hands and they're kind of walking at us
we don't think anything of it and within
probably like 10 15 feet away he just
stops he kind of like grabs her hand
pulls her back drops to a knee and I had
my phone in my hand and I was like I
gotta film this for the guy I wish I had
my proposal let alone my wedding on film
I don't have either so I was like you
know what I just started video in it and
we were within five six feet of them by
this point and recorded it I got his
number
afterwards I sent it to him I was like
hey man Congrats I'm glad I was able to
capture it for you and here it is if you
want it turned out he was a panther fan
it was it was pretty cool and he now has
that moment forever so it was just weird
timing but it was kind of exciting I was
happy for them you're good people Greg
Olson thanks for the call but we'll chat
down the line okay you got it thank you
got it that's Greg Nelson for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app